[Music]
if you love Disney's in wanna as much as
we do you've probably watched it about a
dozen times if this is the case and
we're pretty sure it is you might be
wondering why poo the pig didn't get to
tag along on mo on as many adventures
join us while we dissect the real
reasons why pool was excluded from the
journey first time at the things don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's find out why our beloved puah
wasn't welcomed on mallanna's boat when
viewers are first introduced to Moana
and puah they seem to be as close as two
peas in a pod as a matter of fact hoola
follows Moana wherever she goes with
this in mind many of us were shocked to
see Moana getting on her boat without
her trusted sidekick
since most Disney Princesses don't go
anywhere without their companions many
of us were left wondering why Moana
chose to leave puah
on the shore to make matters worse
nearly every single Moana poster
showcased puah Maui hey hey and Moana
riding the sail boat together so it's
only normal that fans were may get
confused about poo of being left behind
don't worry though your confusion will
slowly start to fade as we get closer to
the end of this video so let's jump
right into it shall we
they're cute Moana needed to do things
alone most of us can agree that making
our parents proud is of big importance
so why would anything be different for
the courageous Moana despite wanting to
take her rightful place as the head of
the ancient Polynesian tribe Moana felt
as though she was going against her
collie
since bending over backwards to please
other people can never make someone feel
accomplished
unfortunately for puah this meant
leaving him behind the truth is that
puah
isn't just a pig he's a symbol Moana
sidekick is a land in who needs to be
grounded however Moana feels the ocean
in her bones and wants to travel in a
way hula and Mona's parents have a lot
in common which could be why she chooses
to leave him behind
in the end Moana doesn't want anyone
holding her back or trying to change her
mind while out at sea
mallanna's quest will determine the fate
of her people she can't allow herself to
have any distractions whatsoever and
let's face it a cute little pig is
definitely a distraction hua didn't fare
well the first time around
leaving your animal behind is not an
easy thing to do which is why many of us
choose to let them tag along when it
comes to puah though Moana had to make a
tough call sure she might have chosen to
go solo but it's not like she didn't try
to bring him along the first time around
after convincing herself that there were
more fish beyond the reef Moana and puah
boarded a sailboat set out to sea within
a few minutes though milada realized
that she'd made a huge mistake the waves
beyond the reef were so huge and
powerful that they immediately knocked
puah from his seat this Cosma water to
panic and turn her back on a wave after
nearly drowning and wrecking her
sailboat what I must have realized that
the journey was far too dangerous for a
ground animal knowing this it makes
complete sense that Moana would want to
leave her best friend on the shore after
all the last thing the princess is is
selfish boat snuck moana took her
father's experience to heart when Moana
first crossed the reef she was confident
that she'd be able to sail the ocean
without encountering any issues well
surprise surprise with her Island still
in view Moana and puah suffered a
near-death experience that resulted in
them washing back to shore it didn't
take long for mallanna's father to freak
out over her fascination with the ocean
causing the water to feel babied and
misunderstood at this point
Moana was approached by her mother who
chose to tell Moana the truth behind her
father's fears Moana was then informed
that her father had tried to cross the
reef when he was about her age and that
his experience resulted in him losing
his best friend for good knowing this
how could want to ever consider bringing
pool along with her again as a matter of
fact if she had let him aboard this
would have been seen as negligence Moana
was too afraid to bring him along it
took mallanna's parents a little while
to accept the fact that their daughter
needed to leave their Island but
accomplishing her quest became a
necessity
once the island's food
I began to run dry while most of us
believe that mallanna didn't bring pool
with her in order to protect him from
the ocean some believe that she was more
concerned with protecting him from
herself after all Moana had never even
learned how to fish
so going hungry while out at sea was
definitely a big concern since the last
thing Moana wanted was to start seeing
puah as a piece of meat this is
especially true considering the fact
that Maui soon joined the party and was
constantly throwing hints at eating hey
hey on another note Moana is a kid
smooth so eating her sidekick is not
something that's bound to happen after
all cartoon characters don't really need
to focus on eating three balanced meals
a day
Maui and puah are one in the same so
this fan theory is a little more absurd
than others can't deny that it makes a
little sense some people believe that
Maui and puah are actually the same
person but before you go against this
speculation allow us to explain Maui and
puah are never seen in the same shot
throughout the movie which raises some
suspicions due to the fact that Maui can
shape-shift into animals this is caused
fans to wonder if Maui has been puah all
along was he choosing to hide out on
mallanna's island to escape to feed his
wrath or is this just wishful thinking
well the theory is a little far-fetched
we can't deny that it's a possibility
does this premise make any sense to you
let us know what you think about it in
the comments mallanna had no way of
knowing what she was in for
all-in-all Moana is one of the least
shady people pertaining to her movie
whereas characters like Maui will harm
others to get what they want
with this in mind mallanna must have
considered the well-being and happiness
of her faithful sidekick puah the truth
of the matter is that mallanna had no
way of knowing how long her journey
would take it easily could have taken a
week or a year all mallanna knew was
that she was risking her life for the
sake of her people so why would she
allow puah to risk his own life when he
didn't really know what was going on
while it's true that hey hey tagged
along and managed to survive this was a
streak of good fortune in the end some
might say that hey hey is the luckiest
chicken to have ever lived do you think
Poole would have fared well of orden
wanna ship or do you think she made the
right decision by leaving
and behind let us know your views in the
comments and that's a wrap
thanks for watching our video and see
you next time on the thing
[Music]